so the screening for this movie actually
have we got coupons so we could have
drinks alcoholic drinks and yeah I had a
couple when I watch this movie so this
review might be this is how I
felt about sausage party sausage party
so sausage party is a very adult very
raunchy animated comedy about produce
yeah you heard that right produce
that you get the supermarket all the
inanimate objects like Brave Little
Toaster meets Toy Story with vegetables
it's very reddit are give a little
sausage voiced by Seth Roy actually he's
a hot dog not a sausage they're
different you look at him he is a hot
dog someone say it's hot dog party
basically the belief is when they're
bought and purchased and they leaves the
store they're going to the happy place
they're going to heaven and human beings
are gods and everything is wonderful
forever and they learn it's a horrible
lie and these human being gods eat them
is a horror movie comedy when that
goes down is pretty great so now this
little hot dog has to tell all the other
produce items and vegetables and fruits
that everything they've believed is a
lie stem so absurd when I say it out
loud is the premise of this entire thing
it is absurd it's actually quite funny
this movie had a lot going for it man I
didn't know what I was going to think of
it ultimately a lot work starting out in
the overall premise worse like eating is
eating it eating's fine right do you
think what does it look like to food
when you eat them yep this hilarious
segment was just like you chose this can
of spaghetti and it's like it looks like
guts is like lying on the ground
it's just the simplest thing ever eating
everyone does it everyone can relate to
it just makes it so horrifying to the
poor food and I like the weird social
commentary that this movie had going for
it remember Zootopia had one of the
funny things about Zootopia is it ahead
like a relevant social commentary it's
kind of like that but a little more in
your face a little more naughty movie
has a lot of racial cliches tied to food
and produce however it's kind of like
Team America or Team America promised to
go after everybody and offend everybody
and they did this movie does a lot of
the same thing it doesn't single anyone
out it goes after a lot of different
folks so if you're gonna get offended
you can but just know that anybody who
watches this movie can get offended by
this movie I just thought it was pretty
well played it goes into its world
building phase about halfway through
where all the jokes ultimately stop it's
not there for the sake of being funny
but it's mean ARC's slow down you know a
c-3po and r2d2 are walking through the
desert you're like oh this isn't
exciting sci-fi stuff anymore but it's
you know building the world it's what
this movie does but for humor takes a
dip but I can see why it took a dip and
you've heard a lot of people talk about
it yes at the end this movie finishes
off with something that is so over the
top just the like we can't do this so
we're going to yeah they go there and
it's pretty funny and if he goes and
goes and goes and doesn't stop and
that's what makes it funny but it
actually for me I mean gross out
over-the-top humor doesn't actually grab
me as much as meta humor there's also
this meta humor segment that I found
funnier than the over-the-top
because in the end sausage party was
hilarious it had all the right players
to bring this absurd premise to life
when it goes for horror movie humour it
hits horror movie humor when it goes for
over-the-top humor it's over-the-top for
sure this is not for your kids man don't
take them to sausage party unless your
kids are old enough to see you sausage
party in which case you won't sure in
the end I really dug it again it's like
ironically it's like if I found the
movie funny but I had a couple of drinks
in the screening does that mean it's a
good time if you're drunk
oh yeah guy knew I was buzzed I don't
know this is reason 151 the writing
really doesn't matter so I'm going to
say sausage party is a great time no
alcohol required ironically and for your
nerdy pleasure this review was brought
to you by a loot crate go to the link
below for promo code Jeremy John save
yourself ten percent on your loot crate
subscription the August crate theme is
antihero so the possibilities are
endless there be prepared for some
Harlequin probably right guys so sausage
party have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
raunch comedy of all time whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you